what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest one punch man
chapter and we finally get to see the
awaited battle between monster god
garo and bang as well as the birth of an
unbelievably op monster so make sure to
stay tuned for that
if you do enjoy seeing these one punch
man reviews channel the cape baldy
within and smash that like button until
it's blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one punch man videos
while you wait for the next one punch
man video to drop feel free to check out
my growing one punch man playlist that
includes videos on all the s-class
heroes all dragon and god level monsters
blast and much
more link to that is in the description
now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all the
cover art for this one is pretty
interesting we get bang
and blast pictured together when they
were teacher and student and they long
for nothing but strength
you can see just how similar garrow's
own look was to bangs down to the
turtleneck and spiked up hair the only
thing is
the 18 year old probably couldn't grow
such a childly moustache
now we get the stark contrast between
that time and now
when the monster garo is facing off
against bang who is visibly affected
and sad about the state garo has come to
as he points out right now garo is just
growling like a beast
and seems to have lost the ability to
even speak bang
is a very cool and op old dude and
seeing him get serious by throwing away
his shirt
is super hyped still though he doesn't
have the thought of killing garo
rather he says he can't let the other
heroes take him down
because as his former teacher with his
own hands he'll make garo come
to his senses bang is the third ranked
s-class hero which is super hype in and
of itself but here he also says for one
last time
he'll go all out that suggests he might
have been hiding a fair bit of power up
to this point
and he might even be ready to risk it
all and go all out right now no matter
what it means for his body later on
if it means stopping garo either way i
can't wait to see what going all
out looks like for this 81 year old
legend the illustrations here are
beautiful and we get garo rushing in
and bang blocking his hits it's a good
sign that he may well put up a better
fight than his older brother bomb as we
expected bang's style is called water
stream rock smashing fist
and you really see the fluidity in his
movements as he sends garo's punch off
course in a smooth way
rather than taking the full brunt of it
bomb actually gets shocked when he sees
garo trading blows with bang at his full
power
wondering if his power increased yet
again so as i guessed
this suggests that bang is stronger than
bomb right now
despite what murata illustrator said
back in the day in an interview about
bomb being stronger than bang
clearly it wouldn't make sense for him
to be so shocked that garo is trading
blows with bang at full power if garo
was able to actually overpower the older
brother himself the only other thing
that could possibly explain this
is that bomb either couldn't anymore or
didn't want to
go full power himself because of what it
would mean like perhaps ruining his body
or something like that a bang sees that
garo
is using awakening breath a technique
which explains why bang is so strong
and able to go all out like this so this
is what i mean maybe bob
didn't use this specific technique while
he could have or maybe he's too old to
even use it right now either way it's a
technique that draws from the very
limits of one's body
and in theory with those techniques like
kaioken and dragon ball z
you gotta pay a price with the toll it
takes on the body
bang is shocked though that garo could
master it after just glancing bang using
it
which goes to shogaro's insane potential
for growth while saitama has this
unreachable level and we never really
get to see him grow
because no one can push him to his limit
garo is like a conventional shonen
protagonist in the sense that we're
seeing him rapidly progress
from fight to fight still gotta give it
to my boy bang
a monster in his own right who manages
to get a great kick on garo
and the dude rushes to where garo was
going to end up before he flies there
and then smashes him again with a tackle
these are some big flexes truly amazing
but what's equally amazing is that garo
is fine
when bang is about to hit him down into
the ground
garo manages to redirect bang's attack
just like bang misdirected garo's attack
a little while ago
garo then grabs bang's head with his
legs and
smashes his face into the ground to his
brother's horror
but it's far from over and i love these
fights where not only are the characters
kicking butt but they also shrug off the
damage afterwards like it was nothing
after such an attack bang gets up and
actually looks more
amused and concerned about the attack he
just survived saying that garo
is now much more worthy of teaching than
when he was his disciple and
adds that he's a twisted punk love
seeing bang look so cool and chill in
the face of this
s-class destroyer and we get another
amazing visual of garo's monster form
before we move on to the also
overpowered
ugly who has been untouchable to s-class
heroes like atomic samurai and his
friends
topic samurai is the fourth ranked
s-class hero so the fact that he's been
powerless against this monster
showing just how crazy these monsters
are ugly was a dragon level threat even
before he got the melting burning skin
that made him even more dangerous and
hard to defeat instead of being cut
apart
ugly's body melted atomic samurai's
sword then the dark tone continues from
last chapter where we lost zambai
a member of the council of swordsmen
this time we don't just lose one
but two more council members as they
save the others like atomic samurai by
pushing them out of the way
of the melting punches i said last time
it was getting darker and looks like
they definitely decided to double down
here
as we see the skeleton of omaha's body
because of how fast the flesh dissolved
nichiren in turn has lost his lower body
and is only fit to deliver some last
words before he goes as well
he lets atomic samurai know that now the
council of swordsmasters
is only him since everyone else just
lost their lives
interestingly enough he uses his
necklace to create a portal and takes
out the sunblade
it's been passed down within the council
and now it goes to atomic samurai
who now watches his former master die
before his eyes
as he takes responsibility for the sword
and for the council it's insane stuff
and interesting too
apparently there is also a moon blade
and when the sun
and moon blades are wielded together
that warrior wielding them will obtain
unparalleled power as the swordsmaster
bringing this legend to fruition is
actually the point of the council of
swordsmasters since atomic samurai is
already so strong as the fourth ranked
s-class hero
we can only imagine how much of a power
boost this would give him so that's
another thing that we can look forward
to as well
to assume that he'd be able to surpass
bang is not a stretch in my view at all
it all depends on how unparalleled that
so-called unparalleled power will
actually be
nietzsche also tells mustachio to find
the path of the sword he believes in and
to follow it and by doing so he'll
obtain
full mastery mustachio cries as we see
fully dissolved bodies then we get
possibly the most interesting thing in
this chapter black ass starts telling
ugly vomit
not to mess with him or he'll kill the
blob monster at first it just looks
hilarious because of what we've seen
from
ugly and because this black s clone is
so small
ugly is confident at this point and
tells the little black
s soldiers to shut up and he aims acidic
vomit in their direction a dragon level
monster turns against another dragon
level monster which is interesting to
see
and ugly says he'll use the black s
soldiers as a form of livestock and use
them for a never-ending supply of
protein
he's so overconfident here telling black
guests to come
at him if he's got a problem with that
the black s soldiers
say he'll regret it and we see some
giving tatsumaki and especially genos a
hard time
by pulling off his arm so all the
different black s's come together
and start fusing into one whatever they
become delivers a punch that
sends ugly flying back and the new
monster
keeps delivering punch after punch even
a direct
shot of acidic vomit doesn't slow him
down one last punch from this new
monster sends ugly to the ground there's
such a gap between these two that it's
not even close which is crazy to think
about
after we saw how much trouble this
version of ugly was giving to the heroes
we finally get the full introduction of
this new monster the fusion of all of
those
black s's lead to the birth of goldeness
who is completely unaffected by the acid
because of the anti-corrosive properties
of gold
the dude is clearly arrogant saying that
all ugly can do at this point is disgust
him
but he definitely has reason to be
arrogant considering what he just did to
ugly since even in the last chapter
review
a bunch of you are commenting on how
strong ugly was
and that you didn't expect him to be
that strong and now we have another
deadly monster who dwarfs him
in power i have no idea how other heroes
could possibly hope to stand a chance
against golden s
right now if they were having so much
trouble and were arguably losing against
ugly
and the black s's can't wait to see who
tries to take down golden s
and how along with how garo and bang
finishes between garo and golden s here
we're gonna need cytomine blast to
appear very soon
otherwise we may even see s-class deaths
just like we got three good guy deaths
in the last two chapters so that's
clearly on the table right now let me
know what your thoughts are on this
chapter and what you expect to see
happening next does bang stand a
chance against garo or will he
inevitably get destroyed like his older
brother
and how would you power scale golden s
so far
could he be the strongest monster we've
ever seen in your view
and who do you think could beat him
right now aside from obviously saitama
i'd love to hear your thoughts on that
and that is it for this one thank you so
much for watching as always
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep them coming then the best thing you
could do is channel the cape baldy
within and smash that like button until
it's blue
if it turns black or white then you just
might not be smashing it hard enough
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one punch man videos
and while you wait for the next one
punch man video to drop feel free to
check out my growing one punch man
playlist that includes videos on all
s-class heroes all dragon and god level
monsters
blast and much more link to that is in
the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one-tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata but they have the
al-jatal dr cortman the toasted chi
the spike emperor otaku spidey life to
nell tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody
hebert and monkey d
quilly and our pro hero to your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel cruz anatoly
kazatsuki very gucci alicia actor bonnie
parks hinokami and water joy and garcia
ted no 10 fat boy games cory mcgowan
metal mama deadly saint and soul ride
slice and dice thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime upper and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about manga chapters anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com anime opera link in the
description if you're interested you can
also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
subscribe button they've hopefully
already destroyed a lot of you guys have
been doing that which i love to see so
yeah you can definitely support that way
as well
and whichever way to support us you will
get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you